video games are all about the challenge
there's nothing more satisfying than
beating your friends last time in Mario
Kart or going on a rampage in halo but
if you think you're at the top of your
game think again these guys took
dedication to new heights to set video
game records that will probably never
ever be broken
longest halo marathon halo was one of
the top launch titles for the original
Xbox console and continued on to spawned
one of the top selling franchises of all
time and while plenty of halo records
have been set and subsequently broken
one record stands alone ending on
October 27th 2015 finnish gamer pavani
Scala played halo 1 through 3 on the
heroic setting halo 4 and 5 on legendary
and then halo 5 multiplayer bringing you
total playing time to a whopping 50
hours four minutes and 17 seconds that
guy's got thumbs of Steel long gets
super smash brothers tournament streak
nobody's going to deny that super smash
brothers is a barrel of fun even the
players who could never stop falling off
that damn edge but some people take
things to the next level one of those
guys is Gonzalo zero Barrios who set the
record for the longest tournament
winning streak in Super Smash Brothers
playing on the Wii U Dario's 153
consecutive tournaments between November
2014 and October 2015
but even Barrios doesn't hold the record
for most tournament wins that honor
belongs to Jason Zimmerman who's won 339
eSports tournaments in his professional
gaming career and also appears in the
Guinness World Records 2017 gamers
edition world's largest arcade machines
years before console gaming there was
the arcade and an entire culture of
arcade gamers people may not go to
arcades as much as they used to but that
doesn't mean companies have stopped
manufacturing arcade machines and in
2015 44 year-old network engineer Jason
canberra's from Chicago Illinois not
only built his own arcade machine he
built the world's largest the game
measures 4.41 meters fall and 1.06
meters east which is larger than a fully
grown african
elephant according to Guinness World
Records it also has the ability to play
over 200 classic arcade games why would
anyone build this monstrosity it brings
you back in time to when you were young
and you were a lot shorter and you felt
that cool experience of being in front
of a video game for your looking up oh
okay we can respect that
highest score on NES Tetris almost
everyone has played Tetris at least once
in their lifetime but how many of those
people are ultimate Tetris masters while
scoring 10000 points qualifies you as a
regular ngon ultimate Tetris master only
a handful of people have ever reached
the game's max score of 999,999 points
on the NES game Harry Hong became the
first person in the world to hit that
top four and he reached it on level 28
his record astonished the tetris
community so much that someone made a
documentary about Hong's achievement
unfortunately Hong's record would be
short-lived in January 2012 new york
gamer matthew Foucault beat Hong's
record by reaching 999,999 points by
level 26 yeah it took him a while more
than seven months but he finally did it
and so far as of the making of this
video his record stand sounds like he's
been set aside cookies here were
confirmed reform control results second
youngest professional video game player
in 2005 Victor de Leon the third became
the youngest professional video gamer at
age 7 when he signed an exclusive deal
with a major league gaming organization
and he goes by the gaming name of lil
poison because of course he does so you
like the little version of the original
poison that cute little poison began
competing professionally at 4:00 when he
participated in a local halo tournament
in New York two years later MLG signed
the out fermented contract with him but
he only cemented his status as a
professional gamer when he placed second
in MLG is free for all halo tournament
in 2005 although professional video
gamers keep getting younger and younger
little poisons records seems like it
will be all
we hard to break all this video game
record holder at the other end of the
spectrum from lil poison Fitz John s8
the oldest video gamer in the world to
hold a Guinness World Record starting in
April 2008 they started recording every
perfect game with a 300 point score that
he played in Wii Sports bowling at his
home in Onalaska Wisconsin by June 2012
Bates who was 85 years old at the time
had a massive record-setting 14,000
perfect matches but he didn't stop
playing just because he set a record
over the next three years basic Yuma
lated another 6,000 perfect matches
bringing his grand total to 20,000
perfect sowing matches by April 2015
that's impressive but come on what else
are you going to do a known Alaska
Wisconsin world's largest video game
collection
most people buy video games to play them
but australian-born joel hopkins
collects video games for the sake of
collecting them as of october 2015
Hopkins had amassed a collection of
18,000 games
it's no popkins over 20 years to collect
all the games but he really ramped up
his hobby in 2010 when he started
actively searching for older releases
around the world of course selecting
that many games as well as 200 consoles
cost a lot of money and estimated two
million dollars to be exact
unless someone buys his collection it's
doubtful a record like this will ever be
broken
beating Dark Souls using nine different
controllers these days it's no longer
just about beating a game it's about how
you beat it we've seen a player beat
blood-borne using a rock band guitar but
apparently that wasn't enough for
Canadian gamer Benjamin Gwynn who used a
rock band guitar a rockin from kids a
rock band piano a Donkey Kong Bongo and
an assortment of other controllers to
beat the notoriously difficult Dark
Souls which is Guinness lingo for he
beat a super hard game with ridiculous
things and we had to make up a category
for it and that's not to knock his
accomplishments Gwyn must have loved
taking on this challenge because he
plans to do it again but with an Xbox
Kinect a power glove and a homemade
controller made out of banana
it's not clear if that's insanity or
dedication but we are rooting for him
all the same
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]